poissy scaphandre pour lui donner un an
david saint jacques était de bonne
humeur durant son point de presse depuis
la station spatiale internationale
mais c'est saint jacques est ce que
c'est et votre journée la plus difficile
pense pas que c'était ma plus difficile
parce que c'était tellement positifs
comme expérience
la sortie là pour moi avant-hier c'était
cité de l'or c'était de la pure
travaille dur mais en même temps de la
pure joie david saint jacques est le
premier québécois à avoir effectué une
sortie dans l'espace avec l'américaine à
mclean ils ont reconfigurer le système
internet sans fil de la station et ont
enlevé un support de batterie un travail
précis une coordination à la seconde
près qui ne l'a pas empêché de réaliser
l'ampleur de ce qu'ils vivent et un
sentiment d'humilité de se savoir en vie
un peu si on veut par miracle comme ça
dans un environnement pareil je souhaite
touchant de me retrouver petits
satellites comme ça de conscience
humaine en orbite autour de la terre
dans l'espace maintenu en vie grâce au
génie humain à la collaboration de
national cette collaboration doit
s'élargir dans quelques années
prochain objectif la mise en orbite
d'une station spatiale autour de la lune
c'est une question de développement
technique de collaboration question
encore d'ingénuité et on n'est pas
encore rendu là encore quelques années
marc certainement encore quelques
décennies mais j'ai pas de doute que les
premiers astronautes à se rendre dans
sept nouvelles destinations sont nés ces
des enfants en ce moment mais son nez et
ce rêve là et dans leur tête
ici au smic rails at radio canada
montréal